[Music]
somewhere somehow I ran across this game
and I really don't know who first showed
it to me but when it was shown to me it
was like wow that was cool and this is a
game between left polygon offski he was
a top top grandmaster in the world for
probably two decades or more in the top
ten and his very very little known
opponent rashid nash medina and when I
say little-known opponent I mean in the
West in the West in the Soviet Union
Nash Medina was feared as a great
tactician and I remember having dinner
with left polygon ski once and he said
you know I must have played Nez Medina
25 games I won half the games half the
games were a draw but I lost one game
and I would trade all my victory for the
one game I lost because this is really a
work of art Nez Medina was one of those
players that was so dangerous that you
just didn't know what he was going to do
on any single day but he was famous for
his sacrifices and here he's playing
black against Lepke [ __ ] is key so
the who plays the Kings Indian okay this
is a kind of funny little move order
right because it's sort of like you're
saying to your opponent you're you're
ready to play Kings Indian but also
you're kind of being a little cagey
you're kind of making a suggestion that
you might play in early b5 or 97 and
early ePHI so but it's interesting black
doesn't really lose any options
he's planning on playing a Kings Indian
I always thought this was a kind of a
reasonable idea for blackened national
Medina plays 'if I've and invites this
ending how many of you think after D
takes e5 D takes e5 Queen takes deh King
takes d8 that white stands better how
many like how many think the positions
even how many think black stands well
yeah it's interesting it's an ending
that a lot of white players purposefully
decline because not only do they think
that the endings even and it doesn't
offer them too much but in certain way
it's easy to get out played with white
so I actually like to play the ending on
the black side so it's not a surprise
that polygon you have skew refuses to
play into the ending takes on d4 takes
on d4 tempo against the Queen Queen d2
that's a strange-looking retreat you
step in front of the bishop right
somebody explain to me why Queen d2 is
actually a pretty good move
not so easy huh actually it's a pretty
good move from White's point of view why
does expecting black to fianchetto as
bishop right makes sense so what white
intends to do is fianchetto his Queen
Bishop to challenge the long diagonal
and the Queen on d2 fits harmoniously in
White's position because it will defend
the bishop on b2 let's see how the game
unfold all very natural
white has a kind of Amarok see bind with
this pawn on e4 and c4 big control over
the d5 square so here would be a good
time for the theoreticians to say white
stands better
who thinks white stands better yeah
exactly white stands better and black
has to come up with a source of counter
play because if he just allows white to
develop his King side pieces - nice
squares eventually this big control over
the square d5 will net white a serious
advantage so black has to suddenly start
doing things right away Bishop d3 Knight
g4 how many saw that one coming Knight
g4 Wow okay that's kind of a leap of
faith several ideas though behind the
move Knight g4 first of all it does
release the F pawn for the typical Kings
Indian break second of all and this is
very important it opens up the bishop on
the long diagonal this makes jumps like
Knight d4 possible it also has another
kind of like slightly subtle idea that
in the near future we might play Bishop
h6 okay in case in case the idea is for
us to control the e5 square we don't
want to see white playing f2 F horn so
there's a reason that we might play
Bishop h6 but Knight g4 this is this is
the attackers move if you will Knight g4
Knight
what should white what should black play
watch it black play
can you play like Nez Medina yes Oh
perfect
don't all shout out once you guys want
to want to become great attacking
players don't ya Knight g4 to e5 makes
sense so your idea is after Knight g4 to
e5 you're attacking the bishop the
bishop would drop back and then perhaps
you would play f5 and then after f4 your
knight would have to move again
yes and when f5 immediately the idea is
that after takes maybe you could move
this knight on c6 to e5 and you keep
your attack against the f2 pawn possible
and there's some sacrificing that might
come about yes amen
do you like your pieces Knight takes F
to King takes f2 and your follow up
would have been f5 I presume and then
okay it's creative it's it's a leap of
faith yes in red absolutely Queen h4
come on you know I mean gift Mead upon
the move Queen h4 is 9 times out of 10
wrong just simply wrong and the usual
reason is because Knight attacks they're
clean I hate that but here white has
committed his Knight - for his knight on
G 1 to e 2 which means that Knight f3 is
not available and the Queen is actually
perfectly happy in the meantime he
threatens the f2 pawn Knight g3 was
forced Queen protects the pawn and not
what should black play
well ideas like 594 Bishop h6 all of
these ideas start to start to become
attractive but one of the drawbacks that
we really have to be aware of is that
white wants to play the move Knight c3
to d5 when his knight is going to be
great on d5 not only because it
threatens the pawn on c7 but because the
open diagonal means that blacks bishop
on g7 is going to be neutralized let's
see what happened Knight g4 de five
castles five go get them
f5 f3 so here white has to be careful
black wants to play F 4 and F 3 right
and then it's just splat it's just
decisively bad and if white had played
f4 the Knight takes Queen takes pawn
takes you can't take with a knight on c3
because the bishop is hanging and black
earns the two bishops and he's doing
pretty good so f3 okay things are
getting warmed up here in our minds eye
we should start thinking about the move
f4 Knight Mac g5 and getting it going
right nice attack go-go-go but we have
to keep in mind after f4 Knight comes
back g5 this Knight is going to come to
d5 and once again white knight on d5 is
not only
attacking a pawn on c7 but it's also
making an attack on White's King side
less likely okay what should belt lack
play what should black play
what are some yes your man Bishop h6
that's profoundly intriguing move okay
so this move I kind of like my eyes a
little bit sparkle after this move
you've activated your bishop
so keep that in mind when you've done
something really good for one of your
pieces in this case the knight on e5
check out what's behind it and maybe
those pieces can get improved as well I
really really like this move Bishop h6
Queen d1 now
why do we like for black one of the
things that we can think about is we can
think about this move Bishop f4 or we
could think about Bishop check King has
to go into the corner and then Bishop f4
right yes in that
right right so we could do something
like Bishop f4 knight on c3 - E - Bishop
check oh how cool is this the King on h1
and then the pawn to f4 and the knight
is trapped okay oh we can think about
this let's say we go Bishop f4 and let's
stop for a second
Bishop f4 and we're gonna give white
credit for seeing the variation you just
pointed out that after Bishop f4 9c e3
check King f4 winning so we go Bishop f4
we're going to give white another move
instead of Knight c3 to e2 we're going
to give white the move Bishop f4 Knight
c3 to d5 tickling your pawn on c7
reminding you about your bishop on f4
you could take take take winning upon
but then you have to ask yourself if
that bishop on g2 b2 is going to be on
an unimpeded diagonal and the pawn on c7
so that's one of the things that we have
to calculate yeah Bishop f4 95 yes young
lady
ah so you think Bishop f4 Knight defy is
pretty good for white so you're
suggesting that before you play Bishop
f4 first play Knight before
controlling the D Phi square very very
sensible indeed attacking the bishop on
on c2 Bishop on d3 pardon me and when
the bishop moves and then you play
Bishop okay so let's just see how that
would go so let's say pardon me I hate
making moves like this because whenever
I make a move like this my rook on a1
starts shouting and screaming and
yelling and it disturbs my thoughts
right so but now after Bishop f4 white
may just try to drive away the night and
once again wants to jump it's a thought
it's a thought all in all all of this is
is good stuff okay let's see what Rashid
played Russia played f4 and this was a
bit of a surprise to me because I
thought it would be nice to play the
Bishop to e3 with check first and I
actually think the Bishop to e3 check
first was a better move one of the
things that has happened here is let's
skip ahead in our mind so we get this
mental image a mental image that comes
to our mind is we want to go pawn here
pawn here pawn here as we've seen in a
lot of kings Indians the rook comes here
in the rook somehow comes to g7 but wait
a minute our bishops in the way so one
of the things that Rashid may have been
thinking is that this was a real cool
move because it got his Bishop out of
the way with a gain of tempo and he
wants to go push push rook here rook
here and he's won a tempo for his attack
F for night back g5 okay
don't burn under tent at them Knight d5
okay so polygon ski says wait a minute
it's not all play on one goal with the
night coming to d5 it will put pressure
on the pawn on f4 and for the moment
there's a pond on C Saturday yeah yeah
so what did Nash Medina play rook f7 I
think that was what I wanted to play
Nash Dina he didn't care about pawns
rooks Knights pieces he just lets lets
it fly
g4 sometimes when we're a little bit too
conservative we miss a chance in this
case I think I would have played rook at
7 as well because I'm thinking that g4
is kind of unstoppable with this move a
tactical theme is possible what's it
what's a good kind of tactical theme yes
in men exactly g3 threatening made on h2
h3 Bishop takes h3 and that's what Nash
Medina would have played if you had kept
if white captures the pawn on c7 but
love he didn't mind he played the move
g3 attacking the Queen on h4 as well as
the pawn on f4 and he's saying listen I
so there's a philosophical difference
going on in this position what left
Pollock I asked you saying is I have
really good development
you've got pieces sitting on a 8 and c8
sleeping
and if the position explodes and blows
up I'm going to be the one in charge
so after g3 [ __ ] yes okay so your idea
after F takes G three
yeah yeah you got it yeah that that that
knight on d5 does protect the fun on a
three yes in bed queen h3 you have to
calculate so this is a that this is a
nice exercise for us to calculate so
queen h3 looks real good
so after queen h3 white is going to play
Knight to except for we're gonna play
Bishop takes that for correct
Knight takes f4 attacking our queen what
do we have to do we've got a sacrifice
exchange right rook takes f4 G takes f
for what do we do
Knight takes f3 check rook takes f3 G
takes f 3 threatening made on g2 bishop
f1 and in the immortal words of Michael
tall the music stops white has
sufficient defenses so let's just
analyze that position again don't look
at the computer for a second because the
move is gonna pop up Queen h3 new
variation okay so just a second so let's
just see what we have looked at Queen h3
Knight takes f4 Bishop takes f4 Knight
takes f4 now we receive that were
obliged to play rook takes f4 so though
the line we just looked at was this this
and I said the music stopped after
Bishop f1 I'm not a hundred percent sure
that Queen f1 might have been better but
hold on
there is a threat of check and takes I
apologize I think maybe Queen d2 and how
many of you like that Bishop on b2
suddenly yeah but let's go back let's go
back we got to this position and there's
another thought that you might have you
G takes f 3 okay we have another thought
here G takes f 3 and still another
thought on also G 3 so we have ideas of
G 3 and G takes f 3 and how much time
are we going to devote to these ideas
right so if we play G takes f 3 we're
really happy if if our opponent moves
this Queen because then we'll take the
bishop and thanks to the maid on G 2 you
can't play so then we have to go G takes
f 3 rook F to Knight g4 but wait a
minute wait a minute
Queen takes F 3 oh I see Knight takes F
2 and then after Queen takes F 2 Queen
takes D 3 great but hold on let's think
again G takes f 3 rook F 2 forced Knight
g4 what if he doesn't take our pot on f3
what if he goes Queen F 1 then he'll
take we'll take the rook he'll take and
we won't be able to take ass bishop and
oh my gosh no Bishop on b2 sure looks
good again okay so lots of things to
calculate and lots of ways for black to
go wrong one of the things that's really
happening is that when we play Queen
here Knight eggs White's King sure
enjoys a lot of pawn protection right
upon on h2 is pretty good young ladies
that starts to look a lot more
interesting because when we play FG 3 HD
3 Queen h3 just as the young lady
suggests any move like Knight f4 that
pawn on g3 is a lot weaker okay mm-hmm
black is beginning blacks attack is
beginning to look really really scary
right I mean Tom takes threatening mate
Knight takes all looks very very scary
Poli guy upski plays f4 so now what do
you guys do huh yes young lady Knight f3
check you rejected Knight takes D 3 why
did you did you reject Knight takes D 3
just because you like checks right the
knight looks good on f3 and the bishop
on d3 ain't bothering anybody right so
ok makes sense to me yeah Bishop e6 whoa
where did that come from
ok let's analyze why why measure Medina
didn't play Knight at 3:00 Jack White
has only one move King f2 and now what
should we do should we continue checking
him young lady
exactly after Queen h2 check can't the
King just run to e3 and it's sort of
like retro what are we gonna do now
became somehow very strangely it looks
perfectly safe
and even worse we've got to worry about
rook h1 when our attack begins to look
like a disaster right I think it was US
Champion John Green John grief who
famously says you've got sixteen pieces
get'em out we've got sixteen pieces get
them out so your pieces on c8 and a
eight are not working get him off the
bench now Knight f3 check King f2 Nash
Medina I've hit a brick wall a full stop
but he's got to get his pieces up with
the move Bishop e6 isn't black hanging
his knight on e5 why not
precisely so the knight on e5 in a sense
is untouchable but haven't you left the
guy hanging pawn on c7 yeah haven't we
left that pawn on c7 hanging what would
we do if Knight takes C seven but one of
the ideas from blacks point of view is
maybe maybe black could take this pawn
on f4 perhaps even with his rook yeah if
you recapture the pawn the rook with
your pawn G takes f for those ideas of
g3 so when white plays the move Knight
takes even he better be real careful
that Bishop takes f4 isn't a possible
answer that g3 takes f4 g3 you see why
you pawn on a black pot on g3 could be
very dangerous right okay let's see what
polygon ski did bishop c2 and indeed
Knight takes c7 Bishop takes f4 would
have been a refutation okay so now what
do we do what do we do the bishop drops
back and white white still has ideas of
Knight takes c7 and maybe his queen
would also be open in the meantime the
bishop on d3 just kind of gets out of
the way of this Knight and white is not
afraid of Knight f3 check so we got to
come up with something
what did black play yes I meant I like
it I like it
the rook on an a8 is not in the game and
if you play the move rook f7 you're
defending the pawn on c7 you could
double the rooks and maybe smash him on
on f4 the other point is with this move
Bishop c2 does white threaten to capture
the night
precisely so I like them move rook f7
because you you're addressing White's
threat White's threat is in fact to take
the knight and you don't have Bishop d5
in Bishop III check our winning idea
because the recapture on d5 with this
check well let's see if Nash Medina
agrees with us isn't a great one we can
understand the moves better being played
rook f7 polygon is key played King up
two and we can understand this move as
well why now we have something really
frightening to deal with rook h1 and the
table's completely are turned okay the
tables are turned
okay so what did russia do
what are some ideas for black yes
okay so you would like to sacrifice the
bishop on f4 but the knight on d5 is
really protecting it so one of the
things you might consider is capturing
the Knight Bishop takes d5 and let's say
after if Queen takes d5 the night before
might be an issue for white to have to
deal with so we might start to think of
Bishop takes d5 C takes d5 Bishop takes
f4 check knight takes f4 runs into queen
here so we do it again
Bishop d5 cd5 Bishop f4 gf4 g3 check
king e1 and we're doing a pretty good
job at sacrificing a lot of pieces and a
lot of our pieces are remaining and I'm
free after that yes I'm lady Bishop
takes d5 indeed they're still rook h1
and our queen is trapped holy cow
well queen h2 check King III so okay
the nice thing and I liked it very much
is that after Queen h2 check King III
our Knight is not under attack but I'm
worried that after Queen h3 check King
III our queen is going to be dealt a
blow with rook h1 let's see what Rashid
did check King
oh okay
holy cow the positions exploding right
look h1 you start to think about moves
like rook h1 in the meantime we're a
piece ahead maybe white should just stop
to recapture that piece we don't really
like capturing with the Queen why not
what's wrong with Queen taxing night
before a queen has to go back to protect
the bishop on c2 and black wins valuable
time yeah okay so let's see
he takes d5 and now
now what did Rasheed play
I'm an old piece grabber pawn grubber -
he's just gonna take your night I've got
to do something about that can't let
that happen
rook h1 going after that Bishop on h6
all kinds of issues all kinds of issues
to be solved what on earth should black
play give up do you say uncle
ah yes young man Bishop takes f4 check G
takes f portlets Oh
when you're on the defense one of the
best things you can do as a defender is
trade your defensive pieces for your
opponent's attacking pieces so after the
move Bishop takes f4g takes f4 was kind
of an instinctive move and I'm sorry I
played that right away
a better instinctive move would have
been to play rook takes f4 so after
Bishop f4 rook F for wanting to trade a
defender for an attacker how do you
finish
how do you continue now Bishop f4 rook
f4 rook F for GF for Queen h3 check King
d2 Knight f3 check King c1 King kind of
dances away
you want me to show you I think you're
gonna have to deal with the knight on c6
okay so if you let's imagine that black
plays Knight on c6 to be full just
moving the night away what would white
do and lady maybe Brooke h1 so we can
hide so we can say that after we get our
night out of Dodge we go night before
the issue that we have to deal with is
rook h1 queen g2 rook h6 that's what
that's what we're facing correct correct
all right let's see what happened 94
rook h1 young lady Knight take C to
check checks are good
I like checks but what do we do after
Queen takes e2 okay true
so Bishop takes f4 now now there's no
roof takes f4 but let's look at the line
again Bishop takes f4 G takes f 4
is there something else that can capture
on f4 young lady your queen is hanging
well I'm not sure it's checkmate but
yeah so let's do it again
rook takes f4 rook takes h2 first of all
look at three is double check King has
to go to d4 Bishop e3 check King yeah
where Queen down but how about this how
about rook takes f4 G takes f for what
would you do then huh yeah or how about
rook takes F for G takes f for Bishop
takes F for check Knight take seats
Knight takes up for night take C to chat
Oh exciting exciting
now we pause we just drop the Queen but
that King is still in the center oh how
can we checkmate the King if we go
Bishop e3 check the King is dancing back
to c3 and it's pretty happy on the other
hand if we could go like knight c6 check
pigs takes King goes to c4 we've got to
set up a meeting that young man okay c5
check I got a go am pass on D takes c6
okay so c5 check okay
c5 check on pass on night on seat a
knight on e5 takes c6 check King c4 only
move young lady
okay so c5 check takes pawn takes a
quiet move you're gonna play a quiet
move when you're a queen down but you
don't see a good defense here and lady
what do you think correct it does it
does and White's gotta find a pretty
good move maybe young lady right Bishop
d3 so we could go c5 d takes B takes but
Bishop d3 to try to get the King came
back hmm how about this how about b5 how
about B 5 B 5 and then I could go c5
check and then take with the knight on
e5 and thanks to the pawn on d5 the
square C 4 is defendant yes
so b5 c5 young man what do you think b5
Bishop d3 maybe I don't know I could
take that Bishop I don't know so who
likes e5 it's a good move who likes b5
who likes something else any other
suggestions young lady
the bishop is once again placed on the
long diagonal it's like a magnet the
long diagonals draw the Bishop c5 check
very exciting move b5 setting up mates
all very exciting yeah ooh Bishop g7 now
one of the things that this does this
move does it's a it sets up some
exciting ideas like maybe the knight
could go to d3 with a discovered check
the King could go here to c4 we could go
b5 check King takes b5 bring this rook
into the game if the rook were to come
to b8 and the king would go we could go
Knight takes b2 young lady
also so Bishop g7 isn't that like a
thunderclap kind of move can you imagine
yourself as white for a moment your
queen ahead and it's light your pieces
are paralyzed and you're facing all of
these terrible terrible threats
what's another terrible threat after the
bishop comes to g7
that there's no way to escape right yeah
do you yeah yes
true yeah right absolutely
well one of the terrible things that
love is facing is that he doesn't know
how to get his King out of Dodge it's
sort of like he's just standing there
and is like a deer he's caught in the
headlights of the car there's another
idea here too that if black could play
be from c5 check D takes c6 b takes c6
there's the threat of names like check
King c4 d5 so white has to do something
white played a four okay so what level
was afraid of is that he's got to make
room for his king he's got to get out of
ideas of b5 and c5 and he stock elected
elected Nash Medina play yes c5 check
with your ight the idea of c5 check D
takes c6 and then B takes okay
any other ideas suggestions thoughts and
lady
right so there's there we could capped
recapture our queen we could go check
King c4 Knight takes B to check King
takes before and we could take the Queen
but he would recapture and that White's
King has escaped the mating that's right
okay ready
here we go c5 check do you take c6 how
are we recapturing
Bishop d3 we've got to make room for our
King to go back to c3 and to escape them
to threaten checkmate of c5 checkmate
okay now what do we do
so your idea is after ninety five takes
d3 check to the King King c4 Knight
takes B to check King takes rook takes
d1
young lady
eat xt5
finally finally bringing our rook into
the attack yes we've got to give our
crits elfs credit for that how many like
that variation bringing our rook into
the game okay let's see here the moment
of truth Knight takes b2 or d5 check now
here I just want to pause for a moment
if we play the move Knight takes B to
check King takes before Knight takes d1
rook takes D one Ruby a check we might
win an ending correct black might want
an ending but it's almost like shame on
us right we the King went from g1 we
dragged the King all the way across the
board and we're playing a brilliancy we
owe it to ourselves as chess artists to
consider other moves check cakes check
now yes I'm ready yes
and
everybody so everybody wants to give
checkmate you did I get it 95 or a night
before checkmate well this game for me
was just an inspiration I just thought
this was so cool he sacrificed his Queen
he played this quiet move Bishop g7 and
I was just thrilled I I mean I must say
my spirits were higher than a kite for
weeks on end as I was just thrilled by
whites by Blacks play pardon me and you
know driving White's King from g1 to a6
how fun is that
and so that really is too you know like
in all the learning and all the studying
that you're making in this camp don't
forget that chess is fun chess is fun I
mean it's just cool and look for
inspiration look at games that inspire
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]